i'm a massive friends fan and i read
that you actually
auditioned for the role of this brain
have you been jen aniston ever had a
moment where you could sort of laugh
about that or talk about that
in any capacity no but i
love jen i'm a huge fan and i think all
the right people got cast in that show
um you know friends was one of those
scripts that was the
one of the best scripts going around
that pilot season so i think probably
most actual actors and actresses
in that age group that they were looking
for probably auditioned for it but
what's interesting is that jen's first
audition was for a soap opera that i got
so we sort of uh have been
like in each other's yes show business
worlds for a very very long time
um and that was a sober soap opera
called search for tomorrow that her dad
actually was on so i did get to meet jen
all those
years ago when we were teenagers um and
we
she was on 30 rock and we crossed each
other many times during our careers but
um
i just think she's a she's a top-notch
lady she's a class act and
um i as i say i think i think friends
with cast
absolutely perfectly it is a crazy time
to be alive why do things have to change
mrs dickinson is the queen of the
dickinson
household very proud if you will of her
domestic skills
but in season she seems to be uh seeing
less satisfaction from that how would
you kind of
describe her journey in season two ah
you know i was so happy with the
development of mrs dickinson in season
two because i think we saw so much
more of what's underneath mrs dickinson
her her longings as a woman whether it's
to be praised for her housework or feel
pride in her housework or be known for
um having the pride reciprocated from
other people and be appreciated for all
of the work that she puts in
um and also she starts to get she she
gets an emptiness sort of
hunger in her belly um even though the
children have only moved either upstairs
or
to uh right across the yard to a house
very much right next door but i think
she's trying to rekindle her
romance and uh physical relationship
with her husband as well in season two
i i sort of you know mrs dickinson is oh
so horny all of a sudden
i'm not sure why or what happened but
maybe she's feeling you know the change
in the air of the times and that's how
it's coming out and this is biggest
i'm not sure my favorite part of the the
show and and
when i just love
what it's doing is when it it has the
the two worlds colliding and clashing
and working
in sympotico like i there's a there's a
an amazing dance theme
um in season two that i just want to
learn every step that those girls did
and
they do that kind of like stop dance
thing and i'm like oh i want to learn
how to do that so bad
and then for some reason when they do it
in course it just makes it
hotter and hipper for some weird reason
you mentioned the dancing
but you can sing and haley can sing
could we ever get a musical episode
of dickenson maybe season three you know
i think it would be amazing if they did
do a musical episode because they
they have so many musical performers on
the show adrian also has his own band
who plays
my son um and anna obviously comes from
a very artsy family as well so i think
there'd be so many ways that we could
fulfill a musical episode i don't know
if it's anywhere in elena's mind or a
brain to do that
but um it would be super fun it would be
really an opportunity for everyone to
show off
some of the other skills that they don't
get to do on dickinson